Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt es Crêpes aber ich hab' mir was Cooles überlegt denn normale Crêpes gibt's auch schon auf meinem Kanal.
[Hamza] *lacht*
[Kiki] Und heute möchte ich euch...
Also: Normale Crêpes waren mir jetzt für heute zu langweilig.
Ich mache Schoko-Vanille Crêpes
und das ist auch ein Rezept, das könnt ihr supergut z.B. mit Kindern machen
weil's nachher - also selbst mir als Erwachsene macht es unglaublich Spaß, diese Crepes gleich auszubacken!
Das seht ihr dann nachher, warum das so ist.
Ich rühre jetzt hier 2 Teige an, einmal einen Vanilleteig und einen Schokoteig.
[Kiki] Ähm...
[Hamza] Zeig mal!
[Kiki] Genau, ich wollt' grad fragen, ob die Kamera läuft. Wie immer halt!
Aber hier kommt mein Vanilleteig gleich rein und hier mein Schokoteig.
Ich schreibe euch übrigens wie immer alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung
damit ihr's ganz einfach screenshotten könnt und nachmachen könnt.
*Mikrowelle piepst*
Ja, da hat die Mikrowelle mir auch recht gegeben!
[Kiki] Das..*stammelt*
[Hamza] *lacht*
[Hamza] *lacht* Weiter, weiter, weiter!
Also ich gebe jetzt hier Milch und Mineralwasser mit Kohlensäure zu meinem Mehl für meinen Vanilleteig.
Der Unterschied ist ganz einfach, dass ich zum Vanilleteig natürlich keinen Backkakao gebe und Vanilleextrakt dazu gebe.
Und bei meinem Schokoteig habe ich hier schon Backkakao mit in der Mehlmischung.
Das heißt ich verteile jetzt einfach die Flüssigkeiten.
Anschließend noch 'ne Prise Salz, die hebt nochmal den süßen Geschmack
Ich fühl mich hier wie so im Labor!
Und natürlich Eier mit dazu geben und dann nehme ich mir ganz einfach meinen Schneebesen und verrühre das miteinander.
So, Zucker gebe ich jetzt auch noch zu beiden Teigen mit dazu
und zum hellen Teig kommt jetzt natürlich noch Vanilleextrakt.
Vanille- und Schokoteig werden jetzt ganz einfach mit dem Schneebesen glatt gerührt, das geht wirklich kinderleicht!
und dann solltet ihr auch keine Klümpchen mehr haben wenn ihr z.B. zimmerwarme Zutaten benutzt.
Ihr könnt auch die Milch kurz in die Mikrowelle geben, die Eier vorher rausholen und dann sollten keine Klümpchen da sein.
Falls doch welche vorhanden sind, püriert das einmal durch oder gebt es durch ein Sieb.
Und das ging jetzt wirklich ruck-zuck, ne?
[Hamza] Yes!
[Kiki] Keine 2 Minuten!
Jetzt habt ihr die Möglichkeit: Ihr könnt es entweder sofort ausbacken oder ihr beherzigt meinen Tipp.
Falls ihr auch mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit habt: Lasst den Teig 20-30min stehen.
Dann verändert sich die Konsistenz nochmal so ein bisschen und ich finde, dass das Ergebnis dann ein bisschen feiner ist.
Und dann zeige ich euch gleich einen richtig, richtig coolen Trick!
[Hamza] Was ist das jetzt?
So, das ist eine leere Tube von meiner Sriracha Soße.
Ihr könntet auch eine Ketchup Tube nehmen, die leer ist!
Und das macht gleich richtig Spaß! Ich sag dir Hamza, du wirst das auch machen wollen!
[Hamza] Ich bin gespannt! Ich hab' noch keine Ahnung, was das ist!
Jetzt eine beschichtete Pfanne nehmen und die schön mit Butter ausstreichen.
Schön dünn, sollen ja Crêpes sein!
[Kiki] So! Man sagt ja immer der erste wird nix, ne? Kennst du doch!
[Hamza] Der erste wird nie was, nie, nie!
[Kiki] Der erste wird immer hässlich!
[Hamza] Der wird immer hässlich!
So, jetzt...Hamza halt drauf, halt drauf!
[Hamza] *mit hoher Stimme* Okay, ich halt drauf, ich halt drauf, ich halt drauf!!
[Kiki] Jetzt mit meiner praktischen Öffnung hier...
So, jetzt drehe ich vorsichtig um...
[Kiki] Das Gute ist, es ist so richtig..
[Hamza] ..fest geworden!
[Kiki] ..fest im Teig, genau!
So! Natürlich ist die Seite jetzt unspektakulär aber es dreht sich alles um die andere Seite. Und um den Geschmack natürlich!
[Kiki] Ey geht da nicht mit euren Fingern rein wenn ihr jünger als 16 seid!
[Hamza] *lacht* 16? FSK 16!
[Kiki] Kennt ihr diesen Witz? Wenn man selber an die Pfanne geht so vorsichtig!
[Kiki] Und die Mütter sind so..."Ja, hallo?"
[Hamza] Zeig mal: Wie machen Mütter?
[Kiki] Aaah, jetzt hab ich mich echt verbrannt!
[Kiki] Oh nein!
[Hamza] Ehrlich jetzt?
[Kiki] Nur ganz leicht!
[Hamza] Zeig mal!
[Hamza] Also ob du nicht Verbrennungen am Arm hast ey!
Guckt mal: Ihr müsst richtig schnell sein, dann kriegt ihr das richtig schön in den Teig!
Hier war ich zu langsam und deshalb ist der Teig (also der Schokoteig) über dem Vanilleteig!
[Kiki] Schmeckt auch gut aber so sieht's natürlich besser aus!
[Hamza] Der sieht optisch auf jeden Fall besser aus!
Jetzt versuch ich nochmal die dritte Variante.
Jetzt versuchen wir's mal so rum. Ihr habt 1000 Möglichkeiten!
[Hamza] Gib Gas, gib Gas!
[Kiki] Oh ich muss schnell machen, ok!
[Hamza] Schnell, schnell!
[Kiki] Mal gucken wie die aussehen gleich!
[Hamza] Kiki hat schon unter der Haube geschaut! Was ist los?
Hör mal! Richtig so: Variante 1 war fail, Variante 2 war schön
und das hier Leute, es ist wunderschön! Guck dir das mal an, guck dir das mal an!
[Hamza] Uuuuuuuh!!!
[Kiki] Woooow! Boah das sieht richtig hübsch aus!
[Hamza] Ja, sieht echt cool aus!
So, das sind jetzt die fertigen Crêpes. Ich find' die sehen echt nochmal richtig besonders aus!
Und die könnt ihr jetzt wie auch normal Crêpes ähm... mit z.B. Haselnusscreme beschmieren!
[Hamza] Hör auf hier Werbung zu machen, wir wissen's!
[Kiki] Moment, moment!
Es musste sein! Ganz ehrlich: Haselnusscreme und Crêpes - es gibt nix schöneres!
Ich sehe auch schon eure Bilder mit Pancakes, mit Crêpes, mit Pfannkuchen, mit allem drum und dran...
[Hamza] Ja, viele machen Crêpes!
Ist halt nur 'ne Empfehlung meinerseits!
Also ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen und wenn ihr mögt, bleibt dran für den Taste Test
und ich verabschiede mich schonmal. Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Du darfst mich aufnehmen!
[Kiki] Juhu!
[Hamza] So, es geht lo-hos!
[Hamza] Ähm.. ich nehm den! Boah, der sieht so schick aus!
[Hamza] Ey Leute wenn ihr das den Kindern zeigen würdet: Die Kinder würden das direkt lieben, die würden euch das aus der Hand reißen!
[Hamza] Allein diese Swirls drin! Und natürlich schmier ich mir da die Haselnusscreme drauf.
[Hamza] Ich gebe auf diesen Crêpe eine Creme drauf und dann wird -
[Hamza] Ah ich hab's falschrum gemacht Kiki, oh nein!
[Kiki] Aah, die schöne Seite!
[Hamza] Neeein, ich wollte das schön machen, ich -
[Hamza] Guck mal, was für ein Idiot ich bin! Ich hätt' das jetzt so-
[Kiki] Ohh, egal!
[Hamza] Egal! Neu, neu, neues!
[Kiki] Nein, nein, nein!
[Hamza] Nein, neues! Das sieht doof aus! Ich will's schön machen für dich. Komm, ich mach's schön.
[Hamza] Okay, Ich nehm'  die Schokovariante. Sieht auch cool aus!
[Hamza] Also muss ich jetzt hier schmieren. So!
[Hamza] Ta-da! *singt*
[Hamza] Boah, sieht auch richtig cool aus! So!
[Kiki] Jaa!
[Hamza] Also was soll ich sagen? Crêpes halt, ne? Schmeckt gut!
[Hamza] Also ich find die Schokovariante auch nicht schlecht. Schmeckt halt so kakaolastig!
[Hamza] Erstmal essen und dann reden!
[Hamza] Also ich find' die Schokovariante auch gut. Die ist ein bisschen kakaolastig aber ich find's cool!
[Kiki] Crêpes sind immer lecker, ne?
[Hamza] Immer lecker, ja!
[Kiki] Und ich glaube warm würde das auch richtig gut schmecken!
[Hamza] M-hm, aber ich finde das schmeckt!
[Kiki] Man könnte es auch in die Mikrowelle tun für ein paar Sekunden oder in den Backofen!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall!
[Hamza] Leute! Für die, die jetzt gedacht haben, dass ich sage: "Boah, mega lecker! Boah heftig, krass ey!"
[Hamza] Ich mach das nicht bei jedem Rezept! Ich mach das nur bei Rezepten, wo ich sage: "Boah, das müsst ihr probieren!"
[Hamza] Das sind normale Crêpes. Probiert sie aus, schmeckt gut!
[Hamza] Mit der richtigen Creme schmeckt's sowieso noch besser also:
[Hamza] Macht's nach und.. äh- Das war ein guter Abschluss, ne?
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] So Leute, ich genieß das noch. Ich würd' einfach sagen:
[Hamza] Abonniert, liked und teilt das Video. Ciao!